[Música]
hay alguna pregunta que ustedes no los
deje dormir
hace 10 años en el año 2008 me mudé a
bellavista con mi familia
bellavista es una localidad que queda en
el partido de san miguel al noroeste de
la provincia buenos aires el principal
acceso a bellavista es por el camino del
buen ayre cruzando el río reconquista
al borde del río reconquista hay un
barrio que se llama san blas
san blas en sus inicios fue un hacen un
asentamiento precario
que quedó instalado en un terreno fiscal
en el año 2009 al lado de san blas en un
terreno privado
hubo un nuevo intento de asentamiento
que finalmente no prosperó
pero esta situación generó distintas
reacciones entre los vecinos de la zona
/ enojo miedo e incertidumbre pero sobre
todo visibilizó lo siguiente
muchas familias al borde del río
viviendo en condiciones muy vulnerables
muchos del lugar nos preguntábamos qué
hacer
qué hacer con esta situación
esa pregunta a mí me viene acompañando
desde hace bastante tiempo pero esta vez
la cercanía y la escala del problema
hacía que me interpelar a cada vez más
qué hacer
qué hacer con la pobreza
es una pregunta enorme
la respuesta que vemos
va a depender de nuestra mirada
desde hace unos años yo vengo teniendo
distintas miradas en relación a la
pobreza
y fui construyendo algunas respuestas
ahora les propongo ir a el año 1984
a mis 10 años de edad
creciendo en la capital de santiago del
estero muchas veces los amigos llamaban
a la puerta emotiva jugar
pero otras veces
su nombre
una niña un niño
son tiene un poco de pan
un niño jugando
y un niño pidiendo pan
ese contraste
impacta
a los 8 años una tía me preguntó qué
quiere ser de grande
y yo le respondí quiero tener mucha
plata para poder ayudar
más tarde entendí que no se trata solo
de plata
en el año 1990 con mi familia nos
mudamos desde santiago del estero a
buenos aires y a los 15 años un amigo me
invita a colaborar en un barrio en el
conurbano bonaerense
estábamos descansando un terreno
y la gente del barrio
nos miraba
y con calor no y un poco enojado yo me
preguntaba por qué no lo hacen ellos
y si no porque no lo hacemos juntos
más tarde entendí que tal vez ese
proyecto no les pertenecía
años después colabore en una fundación
que otorga microcréditos sociales
ahí note que la persona que no tiene un
emprendimiento definido no puede acceder
a un crédito
además del crédito además de la plata es
importante y necesario
que cada persona supiera que quería
hacer
que tuviera un plan un proyecto
elaborado
unos años después estudiando psicología
aprendí la importancia de trabajar para
que cada persona pueda responder a su
deseo y cursando la materia estrategia
de intervención comunitaria aprendí la
importancia de trabajar en el
protagonismo y el empoderamiento de las
comunidades para que pudieran abordar
y resolver sus propias problemáticas
a los 30 años trabajando en un
neuropsiquiátrico en buenos aires me
encontré con la locura pero también con
la pobreza
el hospital era el único lugar donde
algunos o bastantes de los pacientes se
sentían realmente contenidos
y volvían
y se re internaba
eso es una locura
y vi claramente que si ellos hubiesen
tenido una red mínima de contención en
su comunidad
por ahí no hubiesen sido re internados
en el año 2007 me ofrecí para dar un
taller de orientación vocacional a 100
alumnos que estaban terminando el
secundario en una escuela en garín
de los 100 alumnos sólo 10
confiaban en que podían desarrollar su
vocación en algún momento de su vida
el resto vivía en tales condiciones
que solo sólo pensaban en la urgencia de
conseguir un primer algún trabajo
como preguntarse por quién ser o qué
querer hacer viviendo con semejantes
urgencias
ahora les propongo volver al año 2009
qué hacer con las familias al borde del
río
la primera respuesta al quehacer fue
acercarnos
nos juntamos con dos amigos formamos un
grupo de tres y nos acercamos al barrio
de san blas a conocer a las
instituciones que ya estaban trabajando
en el barrio
hablamos con fundaciones organizaciones
barriales redes
familias referentes del barrio y
empezamos a conocer qué problemas
estaban viviendo y qué soluciones
estaban intentando en una de esas
charlas una maestra nos dice la gente
del barrio no quiere hablar más quiere
cosas concretas proyectos productivos
hay muchas mujeres que están solas
criando a sus hijos y no tienen trabajo
al tiempo tomamos contacto con un
proyecto que había empezado en la india
donde hacían bolsas con papel reciclado
tomamos contacto con el proyecto lo
conocimos y fuimos nosotros aprender a
hacer las bolsas
organizamos una capacitación en el
barrio y vinieron 25 personas
les enseñamos a hacer las bolsas
y de esas 25
fueron acompañadas a vender las bolsas
en locales del municipio estuvimos un
año haciendo ese trabajo
hasta ahí el proyecto
parecía que funcionaba bien
pero
al final del año se nos ocurre hacer una
evaluación
y les preguntamos si querían continuar
el año siguiente
de las diez personas una sola dijo que
sí
el resto no quería continuar
cuando le preguntamos a la primera
porque quería continuar nos dijo me
gusta este trabajo me gusta está bueno
y cuando le preguntamos al resto que no
quería continuar porque había estado
haciendo las bolsas durante todo el año
nos respondió
nos respondieron
porque ustedes le ponen tantas ganas
una sorpresa
casi lo estaban haciendo por nosotros
hasta aquí todos mis acercamientos a las
personas más vulnerables habían sido con
las mejores intenciones pero desde un
lugar muy equivocado
ni mi formación y mi experiencia
profesional habían logrado desarmar
los prejuicios que todavía tenía
sin embargo esta experiencia cambió
radicalmente la manera de posicionarme
si hacemos un pequeño análisis del
proyecto de las bolsas podríamos decir
que los resultados no fueron tan
positivos de 25 personas capacitadas una
sola quería continuar
pero para nosotros la enseñanza fue muy
importante
en cualquier tipo de intervención de
ayuda de colaboración o de
acompañamiento a personas en situación
de vulnerabilidad los resultados van a
ser muy diferentes si tenemos en cuenta
sus intereses sus motivaciones lo que
quieren hacer
en una palabra su deseo
el cambio fue rotundo
en vez de llegar con un proyecto armado
desde afuera
y tratar de generar un proyecto que
surja de los intereses y los deseos de
las personas del lugar
dicho esto empezamos a sacar el foco del
proyecto de las bolsas y empezamos a
acompañar y acercarnos a cada persona
preguntándole qué es lo que quería hacer
empezamos a armar reuniones periódicas
establecer vínculos de confianza y hacer
un seguimiento de lo que cada una había
definido como deseo o necesidad y nos
empezamos a encontrar con otro tipo de
respuestas y resultados cuando
acompañamos lo que ella había propuesto
solucionar o desarrollar en vez de estar
empujando un proyecto propuesto por
nosotros mismos
ahora
cómo hacer para que cada vez más
personas en situación de vulnerabilidad
puedan ser acompañadas en su deseo
en el año 2010 armamos una propuesta que
se llama espacio social y empezamos a
sumar amigos y vecinos
la idea principal de la propuesta
es acompañar
a personas de nuestras comunidades que
se encuentran en situación de
vulnerabilidad social estableciendo
vínculos de mediano a largo plazo con el
objetivo de desarrollar
un proyecto fundado en sus deseos
las personas interesadas en la propuesta
generalmente nos preguntan
qué es acompañar
no es solucionar la vida al otro es
estar
estar con él promoviendo procesos de
aprendizaje y permaneciendo durante ese
proceso
y aquí en esa compañía
a las personas más vulnerables de
nuestra comunidad
la vulnerabilidad no pasa sólo por la
falta o el escasez de recursos
es también desconocer capacidades
propias desconocer formas nuevas de
organizarse desconocer derechos
adquiridos y oportunidades que ya están
a su alcance
desconocerse uno mismo esto genera baja
autoestima
desconocer el propio deseo
y desconocer cómo proyectarse a largo
plazo
y quien pueda acompañar
cualquier persona
cualquier persona puede acompañar los
que acompañamos no somos ni expertos ni
mejores sólo tuvimos otras oportunidades
y con quién mirar hacia compañía
buscamos desarmar mitos y acercar
distancias que son más imaginarias que
reales
las personas más vulnerables no deciden
su condición
esta es consecuencia de múltiples
variables históricas culturales y
sociales y acompañar es estar dispuesto
a conocerlas ya comprender esas
variables
las personas más vulnerables como
cualquiera de nosotros y antes que nada
son personas recientes
desean y necesitan estar mejor y un buen
acompañamiento puede facilitar ese
proceso
ahora como se acompaña
apuntando a su deseo la pregunta por el
deseo dignifica y motoriza
preguntando preguntando identificando
qué es lo que quiere hacer para mejorar
su situación
qué es lo que conoce
qué es lo que probó qué es lo que
intento que le salió que no le funcionó
qué es lo que necesita
registrando capacidades conocimientos
aprendizajes y definiendo un camino para
avanzar en la dirección deseada
por qué es tan importante el vínculo
porque el vínculo genera confianza y la
confianza y la constancia
va produciendo un conocimiento mutuo más
cercano y profundo que va haciendo que
los prejuicios se vayan derribando
y cuál es el objetivo
el objetivo final de la propuesta es que
el acompañamiento se convierta en una
práctica social masiva
para cambiar la vulnerabilidad de miles
y miles de personas es una propuesta que
está pensada para replicarse y para que
escale en cualquier lugar
imagínense en cada ciudad en cada
comunidad a las personas más vulnerables
siendo acompañadas
por todos los vecinos
finalmente porque hacerlo
porque acompañar
porque vivimos en un mundo desigual y
muchas veces injusto porque necesitamos
más oportunidades y muchas veces los
estados son ineficientes para dar
respuestas adecuadas y de profundidad
porque hay cada vez más gente consciente
y con ganas de hacer algo
sabemos que la complejidad del problema
hace que muchas veces no nos animemos a
arrancar
pero
qué pasa si nos animamos a
a tener nuevos aprendizajes a desarmar
prejuicios
a cambiar nuestras creencias las propias
y las ajenas a modificar nuestras
prácticas
si queremos transformar la realidad y
terminar con la pobreza no podemos
esperar que otros lo hagan
acercarse
escucharse conocerse
y acompañarse
qué hacer con la pobreza
la pobreza la erradicamos
acompañando lo que el otro desea
gracias
[Aplausos]